>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Pamela Jackson: Good
afternoon and greetings.
I'm Pam Jackson and I am the newly
appointed Director for the Center
of the Book here at the Library
of Congress and I welcome you.
We're continuing on
our day-long symposium
from the Black Arts Movement to
Cave Canem and we welcome you
to this afternoon's panel.
I'm going to mention first that
the symposium today is sponsored
by the Library of Congress
Poetry and Literature Center.
It's a very important component
of the Center for the Book
with a mission to foster and
enhance the public's appreciation
of poetry and literature.
To read about the Poetry
and Literature Center,
home of the U.S. Poet Laureate and
to learn about our many programs,
please feel free to visit us on
the website at loc.gov/poetry.
We have a -- many sponsors --
cosponsors for today's event,
including the Folger Shakespeare
Library's O. B. Hardison Poetry
Series, the PEN/Faulkner Foundation,
and the Cave Canem Foundation.
Thank you to each of you
for your collaboration
and your partnership
for today's event.
So this morning, we presented
a fabulous master class
in children's literature,
and we want to thank the cosponsor
responsible for this class,
which was the organization
We Need Diverse Books,
and we also offer a special thanks
to Kwame Alexander for working
with the Poetry and Literature
Center to develop the symposium.
So this afternoon, let's get
ready for this conversation.
It's an amazing and exciting
two panels that we'll have,
Writing Across Genre
and Organizing Founders.
You can read more about
our panelists
and moderators in your
print program.
And there are two print
programs that --
that should be your seat
and if you need one,
perhaps you can just wave your hand
and we can have somebody bring it
over to you if you
didn't get them there.
One for our two o'clock
that's beginning now
and one for the 3:30 panel.
We're honored to feature such
prominent poets and writers,
as well as founders and
leaders from across the country.
All are here to help us better
understand the enduring influence
of black -- of the Black Arts
Movement started half a century ago.
Each panel will include
brief introductions
by the participants followed
by a moderated discussion.
We'll leave time at the end
of each panel for questions
and there will be a short
break in between the panels.
Before we begin, though,
I do have a few logistics.
We would like to encourage
all of us to be undistracted.
So if you could check that
your phones are on vibrate
and any other electronic devices
that may chime while we're here.
Also, please note, this
event is being video-taped
for future webcast by the Library.
And by participating
in the Q and A session,
you give the Library
permission to include you
in future audio and webcasts.
And to conclude, we will have a
book signing after the panel talks
and we'll direct you to that
location at the end of the talks.
So please join me in
welcoming the participants
of the first panel,
Writing Across Genre.
We'll -- we'll have moderator,
Marita Golden, Marilyn Nelson,
Tony Medina, Rachel Eliza Griffiths.
Please give us a warm
hand for our panel.
[ Applause ]
>> Marita Golden: Thank you Pam.
I'm Marita Golden.
I am the Cofounder
and President Emeritus
of the Hurston/Wright
Foundation and I was --
I feel a wonderful connection
with this program today
and with these panelists because
I am old enough and young enough
to remember having been there at
the birth of Black Arts Movement,
to have had Mickey Giovanni choose
one of my poems when I was a student
at American University to be
published in an anthology,
to have had Audrey Lord and June
Jordan when I was young, gifted,
and black in the early '70s in New
York City look at my poetry and say
that I should keep writing.
And the only reason I'm not a
poet today is because I felt
that poetry was not big enough
for the stories I wanted to tell
which means, the problem was
not poetry, the problem was me.
Because for poets, there's no such
thing as the structure or the form
of poetry being too small
so that in my case, fiction
and non-fiction called me.
I'm also glad to be
here today because,
at the Hurston/Wright
Foundation, we've been very honored
that we have recognized and honored
so many of the fantastic poets
that Cave Canem has nurtured,
produced, and created.
Toi Derricotte has
received our North Star
and Cornelius Eady has been a member
of our summer workshop faculty,
so I feel a real connection
to today's topic,
today's people, and to the panel.
So I will introduce everyone
and then they will make
their presentations
and we'll have a wonderful
discussion.
To my left is my new buddy,
Rachel Eliza Griffiths,
who's a poet and visual artist.
Her most recent collection of
poetry, "Lighting the Shadow,"
was published by Four
Way Books in 2015.
A Kimbilio and Cave
Canem fellow, her visual
and literary work has
appeared widely,
including the New York Times,
Poets and Writers, Guernica
and Lib Hub, and many others.
She teaches at the Institute
of American Indian Arts
and Sarah Lawrence College,
and she lives in Brooklyn.
Next to Rachel is Tony Medina
who's a two-time winner
of the Patterson Prize for Books
for Young People for "DeShawn Days"
and "I and I Bob Marley."
The author of a number of books
for adults and young people,
his works include, "An Onion
of Wars" and "Baroque,"
finalist for the Julie
Suk Book Award.
His latest anthology is "Resisting
Arrest," poems to stretch the sky.
Tony is a professor
of creating writing --
creative writing at
Howard University.
And Marilyn Nelson is the author
or translator of 17 poetry books
and the memoire, "How
I Discovered Poetry."
She's also the author of "The Fields
of Praise: New and Selected Poems,"
which won the 1998
poet's price; "Carver:" --
I love that book, Marilyn --
"A Life in Poems," which won
the 2001 Boston Globe Horn Book
and the Flora Stieglitz
Straus Award.
Her honors include two NEA
Creative Writing Fellowships,
and she was the Poet
Laureate of the State
of Connecticut from 2001 to 2006.
Let's give everyone a hand.
[ Applause ]
So I think we're going to start
the presentations with Eliza.
>> Rachel Eliza Griffiths:
Good afternoon.
It's a very large gift to be
here with all of you today.
Thank you so much for this
dialogue and this conversation.
And to sit in the presence of these
celebrated poets and dear friends
and family really to
me is -- is so much.
I'd like to start with a piece of
writing as I'm thinking about family
and thinking of my brothers
and sisters in Orlando,
I'd like to read this piece of
an excerpt from Toni Morrison's,
"Beloved," and I -- I'm
interested when I think
about the Black Arts
Movement, thinking of Morrison
and her role as an editor.
And then I'll read a
poem by Henry Dumas.
And Morrison was very
influential in making sure
that Henry Dumas's work
reached the world in a way --
he was killed very young,
murdered by the police,
and so I'll read a poem of his
and I'll read a poem of mine.
And then I will share a video that I
created as part of the conversation
of Black Poets Speak Out in terms
of activism, and that poem is by --
a visual poem that I made about
Amiri Baraka's poem, "Incident."
But first Morrison.
In this here place, we flesh;
flesh that weeps, laughs;
flesh that dances on
bare feet in grass.
Love it. Love it hard.
Yonder they do not love your flesh.
They despise it.
They don't love your eyes;
they'd just as soon pick 'em out.
No more do they love
the skin on your back.
Yonder, they flay it.
And oh my people, they
do not love your hands.
Those they only use, tie, bind,
chop off, and leave empty.
Love your hands!
Love them.
Raise them up and kiss them.
Touch others with them.
Pat them together.
Stroke them on your face 'cause
they don't love that either.
You got to love it.
You! And no, they ain't
in love with your mouth.
Yonder, out there, they will see
it broken and break it again.
What you say out of
it, they will not heed.
What you scream from
it, they do not hear.
What you put into it to nourish
your body, they will snatch away
and give you leavin's instead.
No, they don't love your mouth.
You got to love it.
This is flesh I'm talking
about here.
Flesh that needs to be loved.
Feet that need to rest and to
dance; backs that need support;
shoulders that need arms --
strong arms I'm telling you.
And oh my people out
yonder, hear me,
they do not love your neck
unnoosed and straight.
So love your neck; put a hand on it,
grace it, stroke it, and hold it up
and all your inside parts that
they'd just as soon slop for hogs.
You got to love them.
The dark, the dark liver --
love it, love it, and the beat
and beating heart, love that, too.
More than eyes or feet,
more than lungs that have
yet to draw free air, more
than your life-holding womb
and your life-giving private parts,
hear me now, love your heart.
For this is the prize.
For Orlando.
This poem is by Henry Dumas,
"The Coming of Eagles."
Let us have eagles.
Let us have eagles among my people.
The hot wind has melted
ice and the ice has fallen.
The cold wind has chiseled
mountains and they have fallen.
The dry wind has gnawed away
stone and stone is sand.
The cruel winds have cut
feathers, skin, and bones
and the sparrows have died.
Let us have new wings
among my people.
Let us have bones among my people.
Let us have visions among my people.
Let us ride the wind
into the high country.
Let us have eagles.
And this is a -- a poem of mine from
a chat book that I had this poem
and some other poems
included in recently thinking
about Langston Hughes and kind
of The Negro Speaks of Rivers,
which I think is interesting to --
to think about Hughes and
the Harlem Renaissance as --
as pre-kind of forefathers and
mothers of Black Arts Movement.
Aubade to Langston.
When the light wakes and finds again
the music of brooms in Mississippi,
Africa, Mexico; when daylight
pulls our hands from grief,
and hearts cleaned raw with sawdust
and saltwater flood their dazzling
vessels; when the catfish towards --
when the catfish in the river raise
their eyelids towards your face;
when sweetgrass bends in waves
across battlefields where sweat
and sugar marry; when we hear
our people wearing tongues fine
with plain greeting, how you doing,
good morning; when I pour coffee
and remember my mother's
love of buttered grits;
when the trains far
away in memory begin
to turn their engines toward a deep
past of knowing; when all I want
to do is burn my masks;
when I see a woman walking
down the street holding her
mind like a leather belt;
when I pluck a blues note for
my lazy shadow and cast its soul
from my page; when I see God's eyes
looking up at black folks flying
between moonlight & museum;
when I see a good-looking people
who are my truest poetry; when I
pick up this pencil like a flute
and blow myself away from my death,
I listen to you again beneath the
mercy of a blue morning's grammar.
[ Applause ]
And then, the last poem of mine that
I'll read is just one part of a --
a two -- a two-part poem
called, "Elegy," and there's an
"Anti-Elegy," and I imagine these
two parts of the poem being,
as a visual artist, a dip
tick, and so there's one panel
and then there's another panel,
and together, they make a vision.
And so the part that I'm going to
read from is an ancestral voice
and so there is an
element, too, of call
and response which
is the anti-elegy.
But I'm just going to
read the first part.
Elegy. I remember the black
boys and their open hands.
High fives of farewell.
I remember that the
birches waved, too,
the white jagged limbs turning
away from incessant wildfires.
The future wavered,
unlike a question,
unlike a hand or headstone.
The future moved and the
fields already knew it.
I remember the war of the alphabet,
its ears sliced from its face.
I know that language asks for blood.
The children of kudzu, lilac,
the spit of unknown rivers.
I remember the jury and
the judge of the people,
the buckshot that blew the
morning's torso into smoke.
That last morning, I
begged the grandmothers
to leave their rage
next to red candles.
I scattered the stones
the trees bore.
Great vultures came for my children
and black boys were pouring,
wanted and unwanted, and
missing, yet from the long mouth
where their voices were forced
to say they were nothing.
But they were men,
invisible, and native
and guilty beyond their
glottal doubt.
I remember calling out to the savage
fields where more black boys knelt
and swung through the air.
I remember how their eyes rolled
back in blood, milk, and gasoline.
They gave me their last words.
They gave me smiles
for their fathers.
They slept in my arms, dead and
bruised, long as the brambles,
the bullets in their heads and
groins quieting like a day.
I held their million heads in my lap
when their black bodies
were taken away.
I don't know if what's
left will dance or burn.
I washed their eyelids with mint.
Let God beg pardon to them and
their mothers, and I don't know
if the body is a pendulum
of where love cannot go
when the tongue is swollen
with the milk of black boys.
I pulled their lives from the
trees and lawns and schools,
the unlit houses, and the river,
their forewings wet with clouds
and screaming, but
I won't leave them.
I won't leave them huddled
like bulls inside the
stalls of our words.
I am the shriek, the suture,
the rose petal shook
loose from their silence.
And then my [applause] thank you.
[ Applause ]
And I just have one -- the
video, which someone is going
to press a magical button
and -- I will say there is --
it is graphic, but I was -- I made
this for Black Poets Speak Out
and because I -- I felt I could
not speak, I felt so silenced,
and I feel silenced today, in
a way, but I am going to speak.
And so this video is a way for me,
as a poet, to also speak visually
about what is happening
in this country
and how we're really failing
each other and our future.
Thank you.
[ Inaudible Video Content ]
>> Tony Medina: I'm really --
I'm grateful to be here today,
especially about what happened over
the weekend, particularly yesterday,
feeling so disoriented and
numb and depressed all day.
To be here with family
and great artists
in this community to celebrate life.
I woke to the horrifying
news of another mass shooting
and by the time I basically
responded to this stuff
that I was seeing on television,
the -- the dead rose from 20 to 50.
So I just wrote this.
America, you have too many guns and
too much anger and too many TV shows
and movies glorifying violence.
America, you're too abundant
with wealth, resources,
and cultural byproducts
to constantly celebrate
death over valuing life.
It's summer in America, we should be
worshipping sunlight and sea rather
than burying young people
celebrating their youth
in a nightclub on a Saturday
night leaning into Sunday morning.
[Inaudible] for Trayvon Martin.
Skittles back, pock mocked
holy bleeds in rain puddle.
Hoody hides no blood, tears
or eyes shut by wet grass.
Screams pierce night sky, a
father's stomach pits, my boy,
my boy, shot through sky.
Skittles like roman candle
bursts blood from open chest.
Stars squint and stare,
rain drops glare
in moonlight witnessing
bloodletting.
Morning grass like wet face of
boy screaming bloody murder.
Gunpowder blinds the eye of justice
reckless as a dumb vigilante.
Silence of blood clouds
night drizzle
where wind whistles
through hole in can.
Empty bag of Skittles, crushed can
of iced tea, last game with father.
Rain choose night air, nor is the
brown boy flesh grinning teeth
of bullets.
Rain stains brown boy's
back as blood pours
from chest turning
the green grass red.
How blues is born.
Rain falls steady on dead end
street strewn with black body.
Momma's cries hang on rain hooks
ornamenting night wind's grin.
Blood petals pock grim
face of grass like lotus
on rain-slick back of black boy.
Not enough lifetimes to
take back powder burn cries
to piece my boy back.
When Michael Brown was
killed in Ferguson, Missouri,
the next day in St. Louis,
this other brother was
gunned down by the police.
His name was Kajieme Powell.
He took two energy drinks and
some donuts from a corner store,
placed them along the curb
waiting for the cops to come.
He paced back and forth, anger
and frustration stalking
his undaunted thoughts.
He wasn't going to take it anymore.
The cops climbed the curb
with their patrol car,
drawing their semiautomatic guns,
right hand in his jacket
pocket clutching a steak knife.
He ordered them to kill
me, kill me, kill me now.
They lit him up with
nine rounds till blood
and smoke seeped from his flesh.
They rolled him over like a log,
his body's pock marked
skin pouting like lips.
It took all 23 seconds
for his 25 years
to leak out his bleeding lungs.
When the coroner got him,
he asked the officers
to take the handcuffs off.
From the crushed voice
box of Freddy Gray.
I am 'de magic negro,
the black Houdini
who done it, done it to himself.
I handcuffed my own damn self,
I threw myself in the back
of the patrol car, my hands
shackled behind my back,
slave ship cargo ago.
I am the magic negro, the
black Houdini who done it,
do's it to himself, him
black self, see ma' no hands.
I snatched a pistol from the
white man's mind from the back
of the patrol car,
suck on this Houdini.
I grabbed the gun and shoot myself
in the chest neocolonial style.
The autopsy report says, damn, would
have been easier to walk on water.
I bet you a quarter,
he done shot himself.
I am the magic negro,
spineless, I brokes my own spine
after hog-tying myself into
a pretzel, even Houdini,
who done it would envy, only to turn
myself into a human pinball rattling
around the steel gullet of a
negro pickup truck once reserved
for newly arrived potato
famine New York Irish drunks
down on their luck.
Me, moi, it is I who was a fellow.
Oh, hell no.
Yes, me, the magic
negro, the black Houdini
who done it do's it all the time
to himself, his own damned self.
One of my heroes is the
late, great Jayne Cortez.
Her passing just threw
me for a loop.
I just could not believe
that she passed so soon.
Of course, I devoured all of her
work and I was just fortunate
to meet her and befriend her
and she supported my work.
And she was just a
beautiful, incredible poet.
This is called, "Give
me the Red on the Black
of the Bullet for Claude Reece, Jr."
Bring back the life of Claude Reece,
Jr. I want the bullet from his head
to make a Benin bronze,
to make an explosion
of thunder, to make a cyclone.
I want the 14 years of Claude
Reece, Jr., shot on the 15th day
of September, shot in
the back of his head,
shot by a police officer,
shot for being black.
Give me the black on the red of the
bullet, I want to make a tornado,
to make an earthquake, to make a
fleet of stilts for the blackness
of Claude Reece, Jr., the
blackness called dangerous weapon,
called resisting an arrest,
called nigger threat.
I want the life of the blackness of
Claude Reece, Jr. I want the bullet
from his head to make a protective
staff for startled children,
to make hooks and studs
for warrior masks.
Give me the bullet with the odor and
the smoke and the skin and the hair
of Claude Reece, Jr.
I want to make power,
to make power for the
blackness of Claude Reece, Jr.,
the blackness called
pent-up frustration,
called unidentified negro,
called nigger revolutionary.
I want the life of the blackness of
Claude Reece, Jr. I want the bullet
from his head to make a protective
staff for startled children,
to make a Benin bronze,
to make an explosion
of thunder, to make a cyclone.
I want the bullet to bring
back the blood of Claude Reece,
Jr. I want to make justice.
I want to make justice for
the blackness of Claude Reece,
Jr. Bring back the bullet with
the blood of the blackness
of Claude Reece, Jr. I
want to make justice.
I want to make justice for
the blackness of Claude Reece,
Jr. And last, I want to read this
poem -- another one by Jayne Cortez.
If the drum is a woman, why
are you pounding your drum
into an insane babble?
Why are you pistol
whipping your drum at dawn?
Why are you shooting
through the head of your drum
and making a drum tragedy of drums?
If the drum is a woman,
don't abuse your drum,
don't abuse your drum.
I know the night is full
of displaced persons.
I see skins striped with flames.
I know the ugly disposition
of underpaid clerks,
they constantly menstruate
through the eyes.
I know bitterness embedded in flesh,
the itching alone can
drive you crazy.
I know that this is America
and chickens are coming home
to roost on -- on the MX missile.
But if the drum is a woman,
why are you choking your drum?
Why are you raping your drum?
Why are you saying disrespectful
things to your mother drum,
your sister drum, your wife drum,
and your infant daughter drum?
If the drum is a woman,
then understand your drum.
Your drum is not docile.
Your drum is not invisible.
Your drum is not inferior to you.
Your drum is a woman.
So don't reject your drum,
don't try to dominate your drum,
don't become weak and cold and
desert your drum, don't be forced
into the position as
an oppressor of drums
and make a drum tragedy of drums.
If the drum is a woman, don't abuse
your drum, don't abuse your drum,
don't abuse your drum,
drum, drum, drum, drum.
[ Applause ]
>> Marilyn Nelson: I
was just telling Tony
that I can't follow him at all.
[Laughter].
I'm -- I'm really pleased
to be here.
I don't have anything really to add
to what Rachel and Tony have said
about what's happening in
this country right now.
It's -- it's -- well,
as the Chinese curses,
my you live in interesting times.
These are truly terrifyingly
interesting times.
I'm going to read two
poems by Amiri Baraka.
I'm the oldest person on the panel,
so I'm the only one here who can say
that Amiri Baraka, his book,
"Preface to a Twenty Volume
Suicide Note," was the first book
of poems I bought for myself.
I was a freshman in college,
1964, and I was blown away.
So I'm going to read a -- a couple
of early Baraka poems written
basically during the time he was
still LeRoi Jones.
He was struggling with
the question of how
to apply this gift he knew
he had, how to apply it
to fight the interestingness
of the period he was living in.
And I'm going to read "I Substitute
for the Dead Lecturer"
as an epigraph.
What is most precious
because it is lost.
What is lost because
it is most precious.
They have turned, and
say that I am dying,
that I have thrown my life away.
They have left me alone where there
is no one, nothing save who I am.
Not a note nor a word.
Cold air batters the poor, and
their minds turn open like sores.
What kindness, what
wealth can I offer?
Except what is, for me, ugliest.
What is for me, shadows,
shrieking phantoms.
Except they have need of life.
Flesh at least, should be theirs.
The Lord has saved me to do this.
The Lord has made me strong.
I am as I must have myself.
Against all thought, all
music, all my soft loves.
For all these wan roads I am pushed
to follow, are my own conceit.
A simple muttering elegance,
slipped in my head pressed
on my soul, is my heart's worth.
And I am frightened that the flame
of my sickness will burn off
my face, and leave the bones,
my stewed black skull,
an empty cage of failure.
I was so moved by the sense of
fear in that poem taking the risk
of standing up against injustice.
This is another early Baraka poem.
It's called, "Jitterbugs."
The imperfection of
the world is a burden
if you know it, think
about it, at all.
Look up in the sky wishing you were
free, placed so terribly in time,
mind out among new stars, working
propositions, and not this planet
where you can't go anywhere
without an awareness
of the hurt the white man
has put on the people.
Any people.
You can't escape, there's
nowhere to go.
They have made this star
unsafe, and this age, primitive.
Though your mind is somewhere
else, your ass ain't.
[ Soft Laughter and Talking ]
I read a -- a couple of mine.
It seemed to me reading the "I
Substitute for the Dead Lecturer,"
that what Baraka had done was
to create a persona for himself.
He created this persona, the dead
lecturer, and then he killed it.
And then he emerged, his truer self.
And the freedom to create a persona
like that instead of speaking
in his own voice has
stayed with me as --
as an idea of what
we can do as writers.
So I -- I read a couple of poems
written in different personas.
This poem is -- it's
based on a slave narrative
that was published in 1798.
It's the narrative of the life of
Venture Smith who was born in Guinea
in 1729 and was captured as a
child, brought to North America,
served for about 30 years
in slavery in Connecticut,
New York, and Rhode Island.
And -- so what I -- what I
did is write a book based
on Venture's narrative, so it's a
-- it's a slave narrative in verse.
This is called "Keeper of the Keys."
It's dated 1740.
What makes a man a
man is his good name.
The rest of it is beyond
our control.
Trustworthiness and honor
are riches no one can steal.
Let men have faith in you,
hold true to your promise.
My father's values were my sum and
substance during that cocoon year.
From freedom to a new world was
one year of grief, shock, sorrow,
and learning my new name
and master's language,
but not master's values.
Here, at least, was
something I could control.
Here, there was a true essential
eye which only I could own.
Here were my riches.
In Barbados, the surviving
unpurchased riches were barbered,
washed, and oiled.
After a year of misery and
homeward yearning, they were marched
to market, sold, and given new
names, their present strength
and their futures under
white control,
their traditional beliefs
toppled under Christian values.
I was nine years old and
filled with my father's values
when we reached Rhode Island.
From there, my master's
riches sailed to his home,
his keys under my control, while
he disembarked for business.
For a year, I had practiced,
become true virtue,
bring honor to your name.
Now, I promised my master his
keys would be safe with me.
At master's home, his father
ordered me to give him the keys
as there were some things of
value among master's thing
which were purchased in his name.
I told him, my master had
trusted me with his riches.
I had promised to keep them safe.
After a year of becoming,
I emerged, I took control.
My master's father threatened, but
I controlled the keys concealed
in my shirt or under
me while I slept,
more watchfully than
I'd slept all year.
When at last my master
unpacked his things of value,
he told his father he would
trust me with all his riches
because where I come from, a
man is as good as his name.
What value has a man
beyond his name?
Can he control his fate?
Know his death year?
He is richest whose
honor outlives him.
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
I -- I just read one -- one more.
The -- another persona
I've picked up is George --
George Washington Carver,
and I'll just read.
No, excuse me.
I'm going to read a poem
in the voice of Carver.
Well --
Well, I'm going to read
one that's kind of, maybe,
I don't know if it will work today.
But Carver was a very
deeply religious person.
He taught a Bible class once a week
at Tuskegee for the entire duration
of his teaching at Tuskegee
which was almost 50 years.
He -- the -- the Bible study
class started in a small classroom
and within a few years, it was in
the largest lecture hall on campus.
It lasted about 15 minutes.
There are a couple
of collections of --
of Carver's teachings
remembered by students.
And this is one of his --
one of Carver's teachings,
which may be relevant
to the events in Orlando
and to the horrible police murders.
This is how Carver taught
people to deal with them.
The poem is called, "Goliath."
And it's -- it's about a
period when there were a lot
of lynchings in the south.
Another lynching.
Madness grips the south.
A black man's hacked off penis in
his mouth, his broken body torched.
The terrorized blacks cower
and the whites are satanized.
His students ask in Carver's
Bible class, where is God now?
What does he want from us?
Professor Carver smiles.
God is right here.
Don't lose contact with him.
Don't yield to fear.
Fear is the root of hate
and hate destroys the hater.
When Saul's army went to
war against the Philistines,
the Israelites lost contact,
fearful of Goliath's might.
When we lose contact, we see
only hate, only injustice,
a giant so great it's
shadow blocks our son.
But David slew Goliath with
the only things he knew,
the slingshot of intelligence
and one pebble
of truth, and the battle was done.
We kill Goliath by going about
the business of the universal good
which our Creator wills, obediently
yielding to Him the opportunity
to work wonders through us
for all of His children.
That's all.
Read 1 Samuel 17:47.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Marita Golden: I'd like to
thank each of you individually
and collectively for an
extraordinary reading.
Let's give them another hand.
[ Applause ]
And Rachel, you -- you had
the wisdom of a 80-year old.
I mean, that was some [laughter],
you were channeling an
enormous amount of wisdom there.
And Tony, yeah -- Baraka
was smiling.
Baraka's smiling.
And Marilyn, I think that --
you know, when we have these --
these readings like this and
the artists come together,
there's a beautiful synchronicity.
And there was a beautiful
synchronicity to the way we began
and to the way we ended,
and I thank you Marilyn
for ending with that poem.
I think it was perfect.
So we're going to talk a little
bit about the Black Arts Movement
and also as writers
writing across genres.
And I wanted to start the
conversation by asking you each
to talk a little bit about
the Black Arts Movement.
And I think it's wonderful that,
you know, we have different ages
and -- and experiences here.
As -- as an inspiration and
as an artistic influence,
what did the Black Arts
Movement mean to you
and I think we can also think of
the Black Arts Movement as dynamic
and vibrant and still
living with us here today.
I know for me, as someone who
was just beginning to think
about the possibility of being
a writer, it meant to me power
because the -- the
movement was so connected
to the Black Power Movement and
the political changes of the time.
It meant to me audacity, democracy,
that anybody could write a poem,
anybody could write a powerful
poem, anybody could be a writer.
And particularly listening to
the poems that we heard, it --
it meant to me that many of
the most difficult and taboo
and marginalized emotions that we
as an oppressed people
could actually be the center
of our artistic endeavors.
Eliza, you want to start for us?
What does it mean, you know,
that's those are some
things it meant to me, but.
>> Rachel Eliza Griffiths: Sure.
In the moment, I'm thinking
of the Black Arts Movement
in terms of -- of lineage for me.
As -- as an emerging poet, the
Black Arts Movement for me kind
of collages a lineage of
justice, a lineage of power --
that word, I think is very resonant.
But also for me a lineage
of imagination that resisted
and pushed away from the white
gaze and turned its look inward
on its own, you know, black and
brown skin, and what was at stake
for black lives, black history,
black culture, black music,
black art, all of these
different spaces of embodiment
and disembodiment within
this country.
And so, as an emerging poet,
looking, you know, backwards
and also trying to look ahead about
what will poetry be like for me
or my identity, my
experience, I feel very grateful
that there was this movement that --
that really changed the energy
of what had come before it
in very defiant unapologetic terms.
And I -- I like the funkiness
of it, I like the texture of it,
the wildness of it, for
me, especially as --
as a poet who does different genres.
Like, you can be anything.
You don't need permission, you
don't need authority, you know,
open up the door and get
it yourself, you know.
And -- and for me, those poets are
about getting it for themselves
and using that oppressive
language in a way that said, no.
And, you know, thinking of moments
when I have been in a room with --
with Amiri Baraka or am fortunate
enough to be in the presence
of Sister Sonya and so many
other poets from that time
and to see them even now, there is a
great feeling of legacy and lineage.
So I'll -- I'll pause.
>> Marita Golden: The great
poet, James Brown, said,
open up the door, I'll
get it myself.
[ Laughter ]
>> Rachel Eliza Griffiths:
That's exactly right.
>> Marita Golden: And, you know,
it's like Black Lives Matter
could be a poem from that period.
>> Rachel Eliza Griffiths: Exactly.
>> Marita Golden: You know.
It could just be a poem.
It could be a stanza.
It could be a title.
Yeah. So that, you know,
the movement is still
articulate and inspiring people.
Tony.
>> Tony Medina: I see it
in two different ways.
I see it personally on one hand.
I also see it in the
more philosophical way.
The Black Arts Movement to me, it
begins on the continent of Africa,
you know, as people are
getting abducted and kidnapped
and being placed, you know, in --
in chains, on the slave
ships, you know.
Then it comes onto the land, then
you get Phyllis Wheatley and --
and Hammond and all these folks.
Then, of course, you have
that big tremendous flowering
with the Harlem Renaissance Period
or the New Negro Movement,
as they call it.
So that's where the grounding starts
to begin, and I don't really see it
as a movement unto itself,
but a continuum, you know,
it's like the struggle continues.
The art is always continuing
and it's always, you know.
Like I tell my students at Howard,
if you read -- and
this is just poetry.
We're not talking about all of the
black arts, because it's bigger
than just the poetry
and -- and the fiction.
I tell them, if you read the
whole history of black poetry,
you will get everything you need to
know in terms of history, sociology,
you know, people's way of thinking
and how people respond to the times.
But personally, to me, it begins
when I first started
reading, seriously.
Because I didn't grow up with
books, I grew up in the projects.
In my household, nobody really
read except for my grandmother
who read the Bible and some
cheap paperback novels.
So I didn't have any models
as Lucille Clifton would say.
There were no models.
>> Rachel Eliza Griffiths:
I made it up.
>> Tony Medina: So it wasn't until
I really, you know, the 9th grade,
I fell in love with literature.
I started reading, and
then some years after that,
I remember reading, "A Man Called
James Baldwin from Harlem."
Reading his essays
taught me how to write.
Literally, I -- I would study his
sentences which lasted a whole page.
>> Marita Golden: Exactly.
>> Tony Medina: And that taught
me how to punctuate stuff.
Not only did it teach me how to
write and how to use punctuation,
but the things that he
was saying, I said, wow,
that's how my family lives.
That's how we -- that's
where -- where I come from.
So it was reading James Baldwin
and -- I don't know about you guys,
but I used to be one of these
kids that was, you know,
every time I got depressed, I
would end up in a bookstore.
That's why, you know, my --
my crib is like a library.
So I remember one time going
into this bookstore which was
on Grand Central Station.
It was both -- it had an
entranceway inside and outside
of the train station, on the street
and also in the subway system.
And so I would go there and I
would just, from A through Z,
I would browse the poetry section.
And this one time, I'm browsing,
and there's this book faced out
and it's Langston Hughes, and he's
at his typewriter looking this way,
and I was like, whoa, that
looks my uncle such and such.
[ Laughter ]
So to see, you know, a brown
face on the cover of a book,
it reminded of when Amiri was
browsing through the streets
of the village and he
sees in the bookstore one
of James Baldwin's books and he
sees Baldwin's face on the cover.
And, you know, there's a
seismic shift that happens
in your whole psychology.
So it always begins with those guys.
And then , I went into the
military to make money for college,
I get out, I go to Baruch College.
And just as, you know, the
stars align and destiny
and all this stuff, I happen to
take a black literature course
by Addison Gayle, Jr., the chief
proponent of The Black Aesthetic.
I didn't know that at the time,
of course, but he used to --
he used to hold court
in the classroom
and he would just name
drop like crazy.
He's like, you know, Jimmy and I --
[ Laughter ]
Jimmy and I -- and I'm like,
holy shit, he know Jimmy Baldwin.
So I would run to the library
to find all of Addison's books
and take them out and
read them and stuff.
And I would -- after class, I
would go to him and he, you know,
just ask him a thousand
questions, like,
you know, students do to me now.
And I was trying to start this
magazine once called writers --
Voices of Color, and he said, Tony,
just tell me anybody you want.
I know everybody.
I'll get you anybody.
And I just asked him, who
are your favorite poets.
He said, well I like Quincy,
but he's kind of cute sometimes.
And I'm like -- this poetry's
kind of cute sometimes.
Whoa. So I was getting all
the -- the -- the dirt.
[ Laughter ]
So, but in -- in -- in Gayle's
class, he assigned "The Black Poets"
by Dudley Randall, and
that became the bible
and that blew the brains out.
And then that led to me
shifting to also, you know,
include the Nuyorican
poets, and then the --
the Central American poets,
and the African poets,
and the Caribbean poets,
and on and on and on.
So it's a very personal thing.
I think that the Black
Arts is very foundational.
It's probably the most
revolutionary,
outside of the Harlem Renaissance,
the most revolutionary literary
movement in our country.
I talk a lot.
>> Marita Golden: And
the great think of course
about reading Baldwin is not just
that he teaches you how to write,
but he teaches you how to think.
>> Rachel Eliza Griffiths: Yes.
>> Marita Golden: He really
teaches you how to think.
>> Tony Medina: Analyze.
>> Marita Golden: Yeah.
Yeah. And when you mentioned the
-- the book, "The Black Poets,"
Dwayne Betts, wonderful
memoirist and poet, talks about --
writes about being in
prison and becoming a poet
because one day they were shifting
books, you know, just on --
on the floor just between
cells, and one day he got --
he was sent "The Black
Poets" -- that collection.
And from that point on, prison
was just, you know, school.
>> Tony Medina: But -- but like
you said, James Baldwin, Langston,
the black arts poets and
writers, they did to me, you know,
they gave me a voice for what
I was thinking and feeling,
which I didn't have at the time.
And they gave me the permission
to say, you could do this
on the page and on the stage.
>> Marita Golden: Marilyn.
>> Marilyn Nelson: I grew
up with Gwendolyn Brooks
who won the Pulitzer in about, when
was it -- 1950 -- 50-something.
I -- I remember, I
was about -- pardon?
[ Inaudible Audience Response ]
>> Marilyn Nelson: '54.
Thank you.
So I -- I was about 10
at that time and my --
my father was in the Airforce
and we moved around a lot.
And at that point, we
were stationed in --
he was stationed in New Hampshire
and we were living in a village
in Maine and all of our
neighbors said, Marilyn,
Gwendolyn Brooks just won
-- you're a poet, too.
Everybody thought -- I --
I was writing poetry then,
but everybody sort of pushing
me to read Gwendolyn Brooks
so I had this model early.
My -- and -- and I was encouraged
by my family, the -- my --
my father was interested
in poetry and wrote.
And then, in our -- although
there were no collections of --
then it as negro -- poetry
in the school libraries
or public libraries
wherever we were,
I remember we had James
Weldon Johnson's Book
of American Negro Poetry
which I must have read --
I probably had a lot of
it memorized as a child.
And then -- and then
I went off to college.
That's where LeRoi
Jones happened to me.
And he really happened to me.
It was -- it was like riding a
horse and being struck by lightning
and falling off the horse because
he was doing something I had never
imagined a negro poet doing before.
I was just blown away.
And then, after that, the Black
Arts Movement gave me other models,
like Heike [phonetic] and the
last poets and -- and what --
what they did with poetry,
for me, it was not --
not so much what they were saying
as it was how they were saying it.
They were -- they were -- a lot
of those -- especially, Heike,
I must have heard him three times
during my four undergraduate years.
And his readings were unlike
anything I had ever heard before.
They were performative in ways
that I had never heard before.
So that was a very important
direction to be pushed in.
I wanted to say one thing.
My mother was always telling
people that I was a poet
from the time I was 12 or 13.
And when I was in high school,
Eugene Redmond was teaching at,
I think Sacks State University,
and Maya Angelo taught there also,
and my mother invited
Eugene to the house --
[ Laughter ]
so I could meet a black poet.
You know, I was -- I was
a little kid, really.
I'm sure he didn't what it was.
But it was a really indelible
moment to have a poet in the house.
It was kind of like
being blessed by him.
And then, the -- the last thing
I would like to say is that,
when I first started writing
really seriously in my --
in my mid- and late twenties, I
started really writing seriously
and for several of those years,
I was living in Minneapolis
and teaching at St. Olaf College
which is a Norwegian
Lutheran College.
And -- but in the twin cities,
Etheridge Knight somehow
had landed in Minneapolis.
I've never quite understood why.
And he and Robert Bly
offered a poetry workshop
which was called The Free
People's Poetry Workshop.
And I was in this workshop for maybe
two or possibly even three years.
And we met in people's
homes and then at -- at --
at an arts center in Minneapolis.
We met as a workshopping group
and workshopped our poems,
and Etheridge was a really
great workshop leader.
He was a very insightful
reader of our poems.
And then we he thought we had
been workshopping long enough,
he decided we should
go out of the workshop
and take our poems to the people.
And he would say, okay, we --
we're going to meet
at the such-and-such hamburger
stand next Wednesday night
at 7:30, show up there.
And he -- he had a little PA system
with little speakers like this,
and a little microphone,
and we would -- he --
we would go into this
place unannounced.
People were there for dinner eating
hamburgers, and Etheridge would say,
okay, "Yo, we gonna
read ya some poems."
[ Laughter ]
People would put their hamburgers
down and listen to our poems.
Nobody ever walked out on us.
It was -- it was an -- it was an --
this was a period of my life
that was so important to me.
Baraka said that you know a poem
is good when you can tap a workman
on the street on the shoulder,
you know, with a, you know,
some kind of a -- yeah -- tap
him on the shoulder, and say,
would you mind listening to my poem?
And if he listens to your poem and
then doesn't hit you in the mouth,
you know it's a good poem.
[ Laughter ]
And that's -- that's what that
workshop was for me with Etheridge,
but it wasn't specifically
a black arts workshop.
The people, I think -- Etheridge
and I were probably the only
black people in the workshop.
But the people who came up --
Mary Karr was in that workshop.
David Wojahn was in that workshop.
Etheridge taught us so much.
He gave us his heart
and -- and he --
I think he kind of
counts as black arts.
It kind of came at the
-- at the tail end of it.
But he initiated all of us into
the sense of what is valuable,
what are we doing as writers?
What are we doing as poets?
And his answer to that would
be that we are freeing people.
We are setting people free.
And that I guess is the end of
what I have to say about that.
[ Applause ]
>> Marita Golden: Okay.
Go straight to the Q and A. Okay.
At this point, let's open
it up to the audience.
Who has a question?
Mics? We have mics in the back.
And particularly any questions,
though we'll accept all questions,
but that deal with, you
know, crossing genre.
We are running a little tight
on time, so any questions?
Okay. Well we'll start talking
and maybe some questions.
The -- the question I wanted
to ask next was -- oh, Darlene?
>> Yeah. Rachel, I'm
really interested
in the work that you shared with us.
You're a poet and a visual artist.
Please talk to me about how
you bring those two together.
>> Marita Golden: Yeah.
>> And that was such a powerful
poem that you shared with us.
>> Marita Golden: I think that's
an entre for everybody to talk
about working across genre.
Thanks.
>> Rachel Eliza Griffiths:
Thank you for that question.
I -- I -- I would say
maybe for a long time,
since I was a little girl, I
always wrote, I always drew,
I always painted, I was
always a visual artist.
And, you know, in the
last maybe 10 or 12 years,
those two spaces have become
indivisible from my --
my practice of just being in the
world and being -- being an artist.
And so one of the things to -- to
think about Black Arts Movement
and then also to think -- I'm
going to talk for a moment
about Cave Canem is that when I --
when I was accepted in Cave Canem
in 2006, I look around, I had
just started photographing.
I had moved to New York.
Left a very well-endowed Ph.D.
because I thought,
I'm going to try this.
I -- I have to fly or I fall.
And I have no money, I'm moving
to New York because I'm --
this is who I am and I have
to see what will happen.
And so my nice painting easel and
natural light all disappeared.
I lived in a one-room women's
residence with shared bathrooms.
And so in the city, I had --
I started taking a camera
around because the rhythm
of the city needed
that kind of machine.
And so when I got accepted in Cave
Canem, I looked around and thought,
where is the visual record, right?
So in my room where I write, I have
my post cards of Langston Hughes
and Toni Morrison and Alice Walker
and, you know, all of these writers
who I need to see brown faces.
I need to see them at their
typewriters, their pencils,
their papers, and I thought,
this movement of Cave Canem,
we need to know what we look like
in our time and what that means.
And so when I -- when
I asked, you know,
is anyone taking pictures of this?
And this was the 2006, 10th
anniversary reunion that --
that was being celebrated.
I think it was at City College
or Cuny -- Cuny Graduate Center.
Wow, I'm -- I'm old
now and dating myself.
I think it was at Cuny
Graduate Center.
And so I said, well,
I'm going to do it.
I'm going to start photographing
because we need to have a record.
We need to have an archive.
People in this narrative, this
story, need to not be faceless.
And so I began a very
sustained, and it is continuing.
I have photographed may 200 fellows.
And now it's expanded where I have
photographed quite a few black
poets, writers, musicians, across
the board, fiction writers as well.
And so, for me in that space, as
-- as a portrait photographer,
I also felt connected to, you
know, Gordon Parks and Van Der Zee
and saw myself in that
tradition of continuing
that legacy of making an archive.
And in my fine arts photography,
which I think is more
closely aligned
to the actual poetry I write, I
focus particularly on narratives
of black womanhood and black
women's bodies and the narrative
of the black figure in this country.
And the more outward I look at that
history, the more inward it helps me
where language is concerned.
For a few years, my poems and
photographs did not like each other,
they didn't want to
be around each other,
they did not want me double-dipping.
But as I -- as I'm getting
older and learning so much more
as an emerging poet and as a
photographer, they have a lot to say
to each other and I -- and
I feel grateful for that.
>> Marita Golden: Tony?
And we have about 8
minutes, 5 minutes, so --
>> Tony Medina: I'll
try and do it quickly.
When -- when I started -- when
I fell in love with literature,
I was in the 9th grade,
I was 15 years old,
I was forced to do a book report,
or make up a book report that I --
I didn't do it because I was lazy.
And so, I had the opportunity
to make up the assignment
and my favorite teacher was
Mr. Del Los Rios [phonetic],
our English teacher.
He gave us a list of books.
On that list was a book whose
title intrigued me and I was like,
what's an Algernon, "Flowers
for Algernon" by Daniel Keyes.
That led me into reading
everything on the list of books
that Mr. Del Los Rios gave me.
And so my first love,
of course, was fiction.
Then, I don't know,
three years later,
I just found myself being seized by
the muse of poetry and poems came --
came out of me so readily.
And it was like, I would
read my fiction and hate it,
and I would read my
poetry and like it.
That led me to read poetry
and fall in love with --
with poetry on the page and
-- and, you know, Dylan Thomas
and Hart Crane and Emily
Dickinson, and all these people,
and then Langston Hughes,
you know, changed the game.
Also Langston Hughes -- I didn't
grow up with children's books.
As an adult, I grew to really
love the -- the form of, you know,
the art and the text
merging together,
so I started just collecting
children's books
and reading children's books.
And that led me to writing
children's books, and of course,
one of my models was Langston.
I said, you know, I'm sick and tired
of dealing with my own generation.
I want to talk to younger people.
So that allowed me to do that
because I saw someone like Langston
who was able to what he
did for adults politically
and socially also do
it for young people.
So that was like my model.
And since I read so -- so
voraciously in all the genres,
I just always considered myself
a writer so I should be able
to try to write in every genre.
>> Marilyn Nelson: I --
I don't know what to say.
Genre crossing for me has
been -- as I said, I --
I have written what I think of
as a slave narrative in verse.
I've -- what else have I done.
I -- I -- I've done a
biography in verse of Carver.
I do a lot of history -- African
American History in poetry
because it seems -- it
seems to be a way of --
of reaching people
with little scenes,
little gems of scenes
from our history.
And a lot of my poems,
especially the history poems,
have been published for
young adult audiences that --
that's a marketing decision.
But I think it's a good
decision because, as Tony said,
we're reaching a different audience.
You can write for people who are
your own age, or you can write
for people who are younger.
If you write for people
who are younger,
you're both introducing
them to things
that they might not be introduced to
otherwise, you're preparing them --
giving them eyes to see
the world more clearly.
And I think you're also pulling them
into poetry, making lovers of poetry
out of them which I think is
-- is a valuable thing to do.
And the fact that I do
a lot of research for --
for my books and encourage
young people
to do their own historical research,
I've been at schools where,
because they had read my book --
books and the work of Karen Hesse,
who also writes history
based on research.
I've seen kids do their
own research.
I've seen -- I -- I was in
a school once where the --
it was a middle school and
the children had done research
about where -- which homes in their
community -- this was in New York --
which homes in their
community had held slaves.
They had done original research.
They had discovered
things about their own town
that the local PBS station heard
about it and did a program about it.
These were middle school children
who had done original research.
And I think that's a worthwhile
thing to do, to encourage people
to learn about their own history.
So I -- I guess that's the
most I have to say about it.
I don't -- I'm -- I'm
not much of a talker.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.